ah tiens on va continuer de débattre
maintenant sur le nom d'une station de
métro c'est pas une VAN dans quelques
mois la ligne 11 du métro de Paris
c'était ma ligne en plus moi j'étais je
conisour la ligne maie des Lila
j'habitais à mairie des Lila et euhg ça
vous
ça ça vous étonne que j'ai pris le métro
non je prenne le béro d'ailleurs tout le
temps encore bah tout le temps la
dernière fois c'était quand bah il y
avait
un il avait quoi avait des poneur ah il
y avait des premières et des secondes
mec les mec non mais j'ai pris le métro
là encore la semaine dernière la semaine
dernière avec un ticket ou un pass
Navigo non un ticket et il coûtait
combien j'ai on l'a offert ah
c'est C au métro le supermarché au métro
le supermarché on vous offre des tickets
de métro métro mais non parce que
j'étais avec une personne qui m'a donné
un ticket Lig j'ai fait la ligne 12 pour
aller où ouais j'étais
euh c'est PV P Sèvre pon Sèvre 12 la
ligne 12 à Ponte Sèvre la neu la neu ne
c'est la ne
salut de r la ligne 12 à
pon
bien non non mais j'ai pris le métro il
y a quelques
années après celle du pont ça va dans le
93 tu dis pas mais bon vous m'emmerdez
allez là n'est pas la question donc il y
a la ligne du 11 du métro de Paris qui
sera étendu dans l'Est après plusieurs
années de travaux qui accueillera une
nouvelle station nommée Serge ginbourg
tu vois une station qui se situera dans
la ville des las ah oui oui voilà de et
problème plus de 3500 personnes ont
signé une pétition contre ce nom Serge
ginbourg considéré comme un homme je
cite violent misogyne notoire et chantre
de l'inceste donc comprenez-vous cette
décision euh regardez non on va même pas
voir bah voilà je vous l'ai dit
dites-moi ce que vous en pensez oui non
est-ce que vous comprenez comprenez-vous
l'indignation comenez-vous l'indignation
Gill verdz bien sûr oui oui oui Gill
verd oui ce qu'il a fait ses chansons et
puis la manière moi je prends la manière
dont il a traité whney Houston en
l'insultant h ah bah excusez-moi bah il
l'a fait ou pas il l'a fait non mais
excusez-moi cyil c'est le chauffeur de
salle qui fait ah derrière quand je
parle
maintenant c'est
[Applaudissements]
génial c'est génial c'est génial alors
voulez qu' VO la scène avec whneyon un
attendez de minutes je vérifie si c'est
payantou c'est payant c'est pant va coû
très cher êtes sûr c'est pas un ami non
c'est pas c'est pas moi qui produisais
ça mais c'est Lina CIT il y a 30
ans j'ai pas j'ai pas racheté ça
d'accord
merci non on la
pas non mais dit à whney Houston en gros
j'aimerais bien faire l'amour avec vous
d'une
manière je veux pas dire ça
mais c'est
extrm tout le me dit moi la boulangerie
parfois
voil tuis
et ben rien que pour ça pour moi il
m il avait envoyé des fleurs et tout
Jean-Pierre fouco nous l'avait Michel
Drucker n l'avait raconté fait aucune
erreur dans ta vie toi bah si il a fait
ça j'ai station de mtro à mon nom
connard donc toi tu es contre oui
pourquoi pour la polémique bah parce que
je viens de vous le dire la manière dont
il s'est comporté notamment avec Whitney
Houston avec les femmes plus des
chansons qui peuvent poser questions
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas pour qu'il a
une station de métro à son nom même si
c'est un grand artiste signé la pétition
non j'ai pas sign p par 3500 à mon avis
elle va se faire la station de méro je
te le
dis avant j'ir pas voilà non mais
me mal ça c'est pas mal ça c'est une
bonne B ça c'est une bonne B j'avoue
j'avoue là j'avoue j'avoue là là tu nous
là franchement tu nous franchement bravo
non franchement c'est pas nul est-ce que
qui veut dire qui veut défendre le nom
devant Gill Verdez quelqu'un de sympa
Géraldine tu veux pas le défoncer un
peu moi je dis que il faut le faire
parce qu'il y en a marre de tout le
temps les mêm trucs Victor Hugo Charles
de GA machin touts les mêmes noms là au
moins ça bouge ça change on
met vior h des
maesses a FEM fait le
problème été
condamné dire to judiciire ça ve dire
que tu es plus fort que la justice que
tu es
auudessus tu veux c'est le début de la
police de la pensée c'estd que dans son
monde à lui il y a ce qui est moral il y
a ce qui est moral et ce qui ne l''est
pas bah c'est la même chose que les
talibans je l'ai déjà dit c'est
exactement la même chose c'est une
police de la françée B oui tu es un
taliban de la morale en fait c'estàd que
ce que tu veux c'est une société
insipide une société sans aspérité une
société où il y a rien qui voilà a rien
qui
attendez parce que il y a un gars il a
un gars qui m'appelle comme si on était
dans la rue
tranquille c'est la seule émission c'est
la seule émission attendsends c'est la
seule émission où il y a des gars il
t'appellent comme si tu étais dans la
rue
tu on peut faire un selfie le gars m'a
appelé comme un gars qui voulait faire
un selfie dans la
rue qu'est-ce que tu veux est-ce que tu
serais ok qu'on mette ton nom dans une
station service entre barbesse et
bellev
oh il y a rien qui va mais il y a
rien qui va il y a rien qui va rien qui
va maiscon mais comment voulez que j'ai
une équipe de bras cassé pareil non mais
les gens les gens se disent les gens se
disent j'imagine les gens des autres
chaînes comment il a fait 2 million de
on peut regarder on peut regarder ce
qu'ils ont fait un
peu les gars ah ouais avec avec cette
équipe là non mais sans déconner il y a
pas il y en a pas un qui met une dedans
son char les gar gar non mais
franchement on c'est r roqu les gars
sans
déconner
plus le
sujetonz après ce qui est dramatique
c'est qu'on fait un débat juste parce
que 3000 personnes ont dit 3500
personnes dit je veux pas de et on en
fait un débat il a eu des débats toute
la journé sur toutes les chaînes infos
c'est ça qui est drama regardz le
sondage après j'ai un trèè question ch
écasant
sans décon c'est 6 à 13 en une minute
excusez-moi il y a un élève qui a cassé
une assiette à la cantine ou ses parents
doivent payer 3,28 vous avez vu cette
histoire oua ça me rappelle l'histoire
du du vase de Soisson ouis connaissez
l'UR du vase de Soisson oui c qui c'est
qui a cassé le vase de Soisson c'est qui
Soisson c'est qui qui a cassé le vase le
vase de Soisson connaissez l'histoire du
vase de Soisson quand tu au toilettes
non c'est quoi
l'histoire tu connais l'histoire du vase
de Soisson c'est quoi la vanne il y a
pas de vannemi tu connais l'histoire du
V oh là là pour vous la raconter comme
ça j'ai du mal franchement non parce
qu'on la connait en classe ça le vase
Deon et moi mon père un jour il m'a dit
le prof il est arrivé il m'a dit ouais
même le vase de Soisson il veut pas en
parler alors que il a cassé et il com
coup de
sauvage non mais c'est quoi l'histoire
c'est quoi l'histoire du vase de saon je
crois que c'est versinetorix qui avait
cassé qui avait cassé une assette qui
qui va ch c'est pas le guide de graine
Clovis ou peut-être Clovis ah Clovis
peut-être vous êtes comment au niveau
d'histoire
passe moi je sur cl Clov qui avait cassé
une assiette qui valait cher un prix
Curel qui avait fait exprès de la casser
pour pas qu'elle soit saisie et du coup
quand des années plus tard il été
capturé on lu a dit souviens-toi du vas
deçon il l'a décapité
décapité
bra bon alors c'est incompréhensible à
rag son père on parle d'un gamin de 12
ans qui casse une assiette pour la
première fois sans le faire exprès on va
demander aux parents de la rembourser je
trouve ça mesquin ça représente quoi une
assiette à quoi pond exactement cette
somme de 3,28 j'en ai parlé autour de
moi personne ne comprend si mon Beaufils
avait cassé volontairement bien sûr
qu'il il devrait être sanctionné je
trouvais ça normal mais là ce n'est pas
le cas c'est vrai que le pauvre il a pas
fait exprès franchement la base de CER
des trucs à la on l' tous fait tout le
monde CR génial mais en plus là il a pas
fait exprès
faè il pas fait exprès la vérité prière
fois il a 12 ans c'est la première fois
alors l'établissement 10 c'est dans le
règlement intérieur
serurè
j l'argent à la gueule tiens pour ton
assiè mais le père s'est vengé parce
qu'il a il a remboursé en pièce de 1
centime ouais mais il est marrant ouais
c'est marrant ça c'est marrant VO j'aime
bien quand elle est là tu vois elle a
toujours tu le petit info BFM tu vois
l'info BFM l'info qui sert à rien
euh c'est pour qui c'est sy j'adore mais
non j'adore t'inquiète pas j'adore
arrête un peu oh là là j'adore